que dans des quartiers de France il ne
faisait pas bon être juif être femme ou
même être
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
français euh les chéris euh on va passer
maintenant une vidéo diffusée sur les
réseaux sociaux alors c'est un autre
complètement un autre domaine cette
vidéo montre un groupe de personnes de
confession juives euh j'adore c un
groupe de personnes en train de prier en
public alors c'est maintenant à
l'aéroport d'Orly alors il y avait on
avait eu la prière musulmane cette
semaine et la scène se serait déroulée à
l'aéroport d'Orly en dehors des zones de
culte dédié même question êtes-vous
choqué alors il va faire c'est pas
êtes-vous choqué qu' faut dire regardez
c'est
parti
alors êtes-vous choqué Gill Verdes
toujours non toujours non
c'est c'est tout aussi formidable que
les musulmans qui prient à roissi ça ne
me gêne nullement c'est bien ces gens
sont heureux ils sont entre eux ils ne
dérangent personne je ne suis absolument
pas choqué même si la loi leur impose
d'aller dans les zones dédiées voilà
parce qu'il y en a or comme à roissie
mais c'est pas grave Cyril c'est bien de
prier ça ne me dérange pas du tout alors
Daniel mais c'est le même si moi ça me
dérangeait pour les musulmans dérange
pour pour les Juifs après est-ce queil y
aura pas là je là je les crois sans
doute sincère mais est-ce qu'il y aura
pas de la provocation après on n sait
rien parce que si on commence à à dire
que ça ça va ça passe ça non non moi
çaoc il y a des lieux dédiés à à 100 m
ils le font là ça peut être de la
provocation excuse-moi on a été trop
angélique on en arrive à des donc je
pense qu'il faut arrêter maintenant il y
a une loi il y a des lieux c'est très
très bien et évidemment que j'adore
quand les gens prient mais voilà il y a
des lieux pour ça donc moi moi je j'ai
peur qu'on aille dans la provocation on
laisse tout passer on fera Raymon après
et moi je pense exactement comme Raymond
et on a été interpellé tous les deux
hier je crois sur les réseaux en gros
ouais vous dites ça mais si vous aviez
vu cette image vous n'auriez pas dit la
même chose donc évidemment ce qui était
prévu est arrivé on nous a traité de
islamophobe donc maintenant de la même
manière je n'aime pas ça ne me choque
pas je ne suis pas pour je ne veux pas
qu'on montre quand on prie je trouve que
la la la pratique de la religion ça doit
être quelque chose d'intime de privé
donc des espaces dédiés qui sont ouvert
et c'est formidable et j'adore ça mais
moi je ne veux pas qu'on qu'on me montre
dans un terminal d'aéroport dans la rue
n'importe où voilà ça ça reste privé et
je ne suis pas pour voilà et donc dans
ce cas-là aussi je suis contre Jean non
moi je suis pas choqué parce queon peut
pas dire qu'il y a pas de trouble à
l'ordre public alors on peut se
raccrocher à la loi évidemment mais là
je trouve voilà ils sont 4 C comme ça
ils prient moi j'ai déjà
prié par du
coup
chouérop Cho juif qui sont 5 ça me
choque pas c'est hypocrite la question
qu'on vous pose c'estce que vous êtes
d'accord que vous êtes choqué d'accordou
pas
d'cord malêes
mal Ju qui vont prier et qu'on l'avion
il part pas maintenant parceon attend
les00 personnes fin c'est une connerie
ce que je raconte et que tu loupes tes
Corresp et
C
temps hier pareil Raymon tu était dans
et si se passait ça et si se passait ça
c'est pas la question qu'on nous pose on
nous pose est-ce que hier vous étiez
choqué sur les les pèlerins qui
partaient à la mec et qui parce que les
salles de de prière écuménique était
trop loin é était ils ont fait là ils
ont pas troublé l'ordre public là c'est
la même question dans les deux cas moi g
pas parce que là pour l'instant on est
je réponds à cette photo précisément je
dis pas en général évidemment que
j'aurais préféré que les uns et les
autres aillent se se recueillir dans les
salles de prière dédiées mais
visiblement il y avait un c'était trop
loin ou c'était pas dans les bons
terminaux ça ne me pose pas de problème
quand il y a pas de à l'ordre public
clairement sur cette vidéo et sur les
les les pèlerins musulmans hier il y
avait pas de trouble à l'ordre public
mais il pourra pas y avoir des lieux
dédiés dans tous les tous les terminaux
d'aéroport ou dans toutes les G madame
madame s'il vous plaît mais mais moi je
trouve ça
ette
pas0000 est
pour de voelqu
priereéitose que
gens
viem
r accepté beaucoup de choses pour arver
rien à une prière c'est extrmist deigion
Paris oui c'est mal n rien à voirur et
le vivre ensemble c'est trouver beau de
voir un musul prier un juif prier un
catholique prier je trouve ça
très dans
leslis c'est l'inrumentalisation des
photos de ses vidéos hier é
instrumentalis aujourd'huies sont encore
instrumentalisé le pays suffisamment
fracturé pour pas utiliser ces photos
pour essayer de monter les uns contre
lesutant hier comme aujourd'hui donc
c'est çaè mais en quoi nous on
instrumentalise plus que vous en fait en
disant ça je te parle pas r générale par
que vous vous avez l' hyper gentil hyper
humain hyper ouvert hyper tolérant et en
fait c'est c'est vous nous rendez nous
hyper raciste hyper islamophobe tout ce
qu'on dit hyperors c'est mal c'est mal
de prier par les temps qui court quand
on est musulman ou quand on est juif
parce que ça va vous êtes vous êtes
choqué oui je suis choqué parce que on
prie chez soi tout simplement en fait il
y a rien d'autre à dire on prie chez soi
dans un lieu de culte dans un lie culte
mais pas dans un lieu public Ahou bah
oui en ils ont pas le choix ils prennent
l'avion des prières régulières à
certaines heures liedi il a des lieux
dédiés c'est comme la dernière fois je
pense que ce qu'on se disait avec
mooktar c'est que l'avion était en
retard et que voilà et que ils ont ils
avent pas ils avaient pas le temps de se
rend se rendre dans la dans la salle de
prière et là là aussi il devait prier
bon vous vous oui oui mais c'est
toujours pare cette photo là elle est
pas choquante moi je trouve qu'il y a
rien de plus beau que des gens qui
prient donc ça m'embête de mettre oui je
suis choqué il faut juste voir plus plus
loin que ça je suis désolé si alors
alors si on si ça ça nous choque pas 5
si on a 1000 pourquoi ça nous choquerait
pourquoi pourquoi on en voudrait à 1000
personnes et pour c'est pas choquant je
c'est pas choquant est-ce qu'on est
d'accord ou est-ce qu'on est pas
d'accord que tout le monde s'amuse à
prier partout dans les
li
comprends non culture jou pas làdessus
je prends les mots comme sort je pas
làdessus je vous ai dit l'autre fois que
ce soit catholique juif ou musulman je
suis pas choé je suis pas d'accord on
est venu m'interpeller sur les réseaux
sociaux en montrant ça qu'est-ce que tu
en penses qu'est-ce que tu en passe
alors je vous le dis je le dis que ce
soit un juif qui prie comme ça que ce
soit un musulman un catholique je ne
suis pas d'accord je suis pas choqué
s'ils veulent prier 20 personnes ça me
dérange pas mais je ne suis pas d'accord
et je suis très content que ça passe ça
et je suis très content qu'on le passe
là parce que les gens disent ouais c'est
que des musulmans ça aurait été des
Juifs vous l'aurez pas passé tiens votre
réponse elle est là on passe quand même
que ce soit juif musulman on passe quand
même voilà et moi je reste sur ma je
reste sur ma ligne je suis pas en train
de faire du de l'eau tiède oui parce que
jeux pas qu'on m'insulte dehors alors je
vais dire oui c'est facile à dire non ça
me choque pas c'est facile à dire là à
la télé je suis pas choqué ils ont le
droit c'est des religions de paix et
d'amour ils ont le droit de faire la
prière ça ne me dérange
pas
me je trouve Raymon que tu as le droit
d'avoir ta position en revanche ne ni
pas la nôtre en disant que si on on a
cette position là parce que soit-disant
nous n'aurions pas de coroness pardon
c'est extrêmement désagréable pour nous
on a le droit d'avoir une position elle
elle n'est pas conforme à la tienne mais
ne nous dit pas que parce qu'on on l'a
parce qu'on est pas on on n pas on est
tiè ou ceci ou cela moi comme pour lesul
je suis répondre parce je ne suis pas
choqué il s'agit encore une fois de
trois ou quatre personnes je pense qu'il
faut se calmer un peu Mo j'ai pas voilà
fa tout le monde
redescend ben ou ben je te dis je te dis
ce que je pense c'est pas une question
il y a plein de thèmes sur lesquels je
suis désolé je me suis retrouvé tout
seul donc c'est pas une question de
courage ne nous fait pas ce procès là
moi je considère que c'est TR
person aussi c'était trois ou quatre
personnes demain ce sera peut-être des
catholiques ou des bouddhistes je m'en
fous je considère qu'il y a d'autres
combats à mener aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
ça ne me choque pas au sens où c'est la
question qui est posée ça ne me choque
pas en revanche oui je suis d'accord la
religion c'est quelque chose d'intime
qui s'exerce chez soi mais calmons-nous
un peu
quoi je vis répondre à Raymond très
gentiment Raymond dit vous n'avez pas la
même position ici que dehors excuse-moi
Raymon j'ai la même position partout
j'ai jamais changé et d'autre part et
d'autre part Raymon et géradine explique
explique que là il y en a il y a 5
personnes qui pris 30 et si c'était 300
et ben moi je vous le dis si c'est 300
c'est tout aussi formidable le nom n'a
rien à voir là-dedansce que c'estce que
c'est ce
délire tous même temps laiss finir laiss
finir laiss finir Terri que vous alors
attendez c'est encore pire parce que non
mais laissez-moi finir là vous dites
c'est pas gênant parce qu'ils sont dans
leur coin ils sont C ou c'est pas mais
laissez-moi finir ma phrase ou c'est pas
gênant parce que ils sont 30 quand
c'était les musulmans mais si ils sont
300 quel est le problème 300 personnes
qui pr
ensemble tu fais savoir de de pas
comprendre pourquoi on dit que c'est pas
pareil si je passe dans la rue qu' a un
mec en train de pisser ça me g pas en
[Applaudissements]
de les musulans ou les Juifs c'est
exactement ce que je vous ai expliqué
avanier ou hier so viens dire 20 ça me
dérange pas je m'en fous le jour o on a
300 vouses non non ça dérange pas vous
venez
deoute parler vous
vene
dér
l'éroport ça va
faire nom
est comm ça c'est trèsair c'est très
pour tout le monde pour toutes les
religions on parle plus et voilà pas
probl
par comme dans la justice il y a une
question de proportionnalité et il y a
une question aussi voilà s' y a deux
personnes qui sont assis sur un coin et
qui sont en train de prier ça gênera
personne personne le verra à partir du
moment où il y en a 50 100 150 oui c'est
autre
chose fin c'est insupportable
insupportable non mais je vous dis si
c'est vous
insupportable je dis comme il y a la loi
et l'esprit de la loi et là
effectivement soyons PRAG on est dans
dans une situation actuellement où déjà
la France elle est fracturéeù il y a des
tensions évitons de mettre de l'huile
sur le feu ça là pour l'instant il y a
dans cette image là et dans la dans la
précédente qu'on nous avait montré des
pèlerins qui allaient à la mec il n'y
avait aucune aucun aucun trouble à
l'ordre public à partir du moment où il
y a aucun trouble à l'ordre public ne
rajoutons pas de lui sur le feu si là il
y avait 200 pèlerins juifs ou 200
pèlerins musulmans qui bloquent
l'aéroport et qui et qui pour le coup
EMB bête et font et font du trouble à
l'ordre public ma position elle serait
différente et dir ion ça t'aurait
dérangé S a quoi c'est
dire vousêes de regarde regarde là sur
cette image il ne gêne
personnerê agressif je te POS une
questionans musul qui pr tu me fais de
la politique fiction je te demande si
cette image te
Cho ch person
autour qui prie est-ce que ça te choque
ou
pas tu pas répondre êes de l' pouro
ch c'est un aéroport c'est pas une
MOS ce soit une priè facile à
comprendre question c'est le fond
pourquoi ça te choque qu'il a des
musulmans ou des juif qui pr par aur
beaucoup de monde qui vont prier ça va
peutêtre gêner le fonctionnement c'est
pas comme sil faisait un match de foot
là on parle d'une prière c'est le F la
religion qui ch
mais mais allons allons au fond du sujet
allons au fond du sujet vraiment on
parle pas de 100 personnes qui font une
activité on parle pas de 100 personnes
qui jou qui F tennis'estce qui te
ch qui te choque dans le fond qu'il y a
un certain nombre de personnes pourquoi
pass qui fassent une prière juif
musulman que la foi la spiritualité
c'est quelque chose de privé et d'intime
et elle ne me regarde pas je veux pas
qu'on s vous plaît jaard avait une
question pour imagine tu es mère d'une
commune il y a qu ou C personnes devant
une mosquée qui prie dehors c'est pas
tellement trouble à l'ordre public a TR
ou qure personnes en revanche il y en a
500 qui prie parce que la population a
augmenté est-ce que là tu vas pas
prendre des décisions pour qu'il puisse
prier tu vas rien faireis vendredi tu
sais ce que je fais le vendredi pass
argent
r le vendredi les ru elles sont barrées
avec la mosquée tu es obligé de faire
des détours il y a des bouchons à
jeuneviler la mosquée de jeunevil c'est
pareil le vendredi tu peux pas te garer
nulle part parce que les place de
parking il y en a plus nulle part les
rues quand tu sors à 14h tu es dans les
bouchons pendant 20 30 minutes tu es
dans les bouchons ça me dérange pas
tolérance ils sortent d'un lieu de culte
ça ne me dérange pas ils sortent de leur
mosqu pris un jour un jour tuas pas pris
d'amende j'ai pris une Amand parce que
je sais ou tu fous de ma
gueule là vous me faites passer pour un
fachot vous me faites passer pour un fa
passer pour le me est contre religion je
suis peut-être pas le plus tolérant j'ai
pas cette prétention je suis tolérant
avec les religions quand je vais au
Maroc je suis tolérant quand je suis
avec Cyril on fait Chabbat je suis
tolérant je mets laquipa je va dans il y
a pas as vu ce que don
mais là mais là je non mais je passe
pour un abruti en fait il fait 2 minutes
de prière il se démonte il va pas êère
moi je fais pas d'è je dis pas 5 ça me
dérange pas 200 ça dérange vraent moi je
fais pas de procès je te fais aucun
procès je dis juste qu'il y a une
différence entre trois personnes qui
prient devant un local dans une rue ou
dans un aéroport et 300 ou 400 parce REP
c'est ce que j'ai dit hier fais le
replay
ex ce sout pas
mettre pas mettre il y a gens qui voudra
s'exprimer s'il vous plaît Jean fer
oui mais c'est passionnant la religion
je me prends je suis blessé moi par ce
que j'entends c'estàdire que là on est
en train d'établir des jauges vous vous
rendez compte du du mot j'ai entendu le
mot ja il y a des jauges alors à 100 on
est encore ok à 200 on est plus ok vous
rendez compte de ce que vous dites vous
êtes en train de dire et et votre
discours il va vous mener où il va vous
mener bon alors s'il y a 300 musulmans
quelque part là c'est trop un trouble
juif trouble ordre publ et ce vous êtes
malous
VI une
comm faut quand on v dans une communauté
où chacun des idées différentes on
essaie que chacun que ses idées ne soi
pas gênantes pour les autres donc TR oui
TR évidment pour mais parce que ça peut
ger les autres aut
r son pas confoup pour être gêné ou ceux
qui sont qui mais j'ai pas les noms
cétait con quoi j'ai pas les nom voilà
c'est ça votre
problème qui personne qui qui tu parles
tu parles tu parles toujours des
confessions il y a plein de gens qui son
qui c'est Ding c'est abstrait votre truc
en G il y a les Ath par exemple les a
ils ont pas envie d'être gênés dans leur
environnement comme ça donc Chac c'est
une question de bon sens il pas pourquoi
tu parles de jauge c'est n'importe
quoi
'est-ce que tu veux qu'il dis qu'est-ce
que tu veux qu'
disconnect de
la mais qu'estce to
[Applaudissements]
pizzaoloain avoir un argument donc tu tu
à nouveau tu nous fais ton numéro de
claquette pourquoi je parlais de
proportionnalité tout à l'heure parce
que ce sont des cas qui sont déjà
présentés que tu as 400 personnes qui se
vont devant un bâtiment et que a pas
assz de monde le maire prend une
décision et il va éventuellement faire
faire construire une mosquée bah oui
mais ce sont des cas sont des cas
concrets dont je te parle donc c'est pas
oui la question de la proportionnalité
c'est une question et tu vas avoir des
gens autour du quartier qui vont se
plaindre qui vont écrire
au les mariages quand il a des mariages
tout le monde est d'accord pour que
dehors on J des grains de riz on chante
on célèbre les mariés quand il y a des
rodéos que ça bouche les res les rues
qu'il y a des roues arrièr c'est un
bordel total et ben non là on réglemente
mais qu' son de bon sens le rodéo à un
ou à 1000 c'est interdit par la loi
monsieur c'est pas pareil on peut jeter
du riz sore r riz B oui mais texplique
justement mais je t'explique justement
que les débordements c'est les rodéos et
quand c'est quand c'est limité comme ça
tout le monde accepte et tout le monde
comprend PLA s'il plaît juste juste
est-ce que tu as une question à
poser
ça aussi écoutez c'est ça c'est dur ce
que vous allez entendre
écoutez moi j'ai une question moi j'ai
une vraie question s'il vous plaît
laissez-moi finir moi j'ai une vraie
question est-ce que vous savez pourquoi
il y a pas trop d'enfants dans les
écoles à
gazar parce qu'on a tué parce qu'on a
tué tous les enfants
Dar il y a plus rien dans les classes
Dar ils vont finir sous les
encombres c'est catastrophique
catastrophique catastrophique c'est tout
ce qu'on veut pas là ce qu'on a montré
les deux vidéos là c'est catastrophique
euh d'un côté comme de l'autre c'est
voilà je vous dis ça ça ça c'est pareil
he sanction hein pour
moi comment ça peut être diffusé Cyril
comment ça peut pass les réseaux me
rendre fou et quand j'entends ça sur les
réseaux quand je vois l'autre là et
quand je vois ça sur les réseaux je vous
dis il faut arrêter les réseaux moi je
je je vous dis quand euh je dis voilà je
je vous le disais souvent arrêtez les
réseaux arrêtez c'est insupportable
d'entendre ça on ne veut pas entendre
des choses comme ça mais vous rendez
compte c'est terrible he on parle
d'enfants terrible terrible parle on
parle d'enfant on parle d'enfant parle
d'un bébé avant on parle d'enfant
maintenant c'est pas possible c'est
devenu l'escalade je vous le dis il y a
une escalade qui est inadmissible et et
et ça c'est sanction pour alors c'est un
délit c'est 7 ans de prison et 100000 €
d'ement Ren a jamais
rien retrouver parce que là la fille là
qui est complètement débile juste même
chose
pour
le problème c'est l'anony sur Internet
c'est l'anony sur
Internet
maisandulté
louisard ou tu peux pas t'excuser
d'avoir lancé par que je suis dit c'est
pas parce que je vais m'excuser ça alors
c'est mieux de s'excuser mais je vous
dire par fait encore la maline mais de
pas faire ça moi tomber sur une chanson
comme ça sur un mec qui chante ça je
vous dis ça ça ça non mais tu as envie
de pleurer je te dis franchement tu as
envie de pleurer oui Kelly oui mais là
par exemple la nana qui était à visage
découvert elle elle va sûrement avoir
des problèmes il y a quelque chose
derrière là je reviens avec ce que ce
que disait Bernard moi ça fait 100 ans
qu'on le dit ici sur ce plateau mais en
fait à partir du moment où t enlève
l'anonymat mais tout pour moi beaucoup
de choses sont réglées déjà parce que
les personnes elles sont traçables elles
sont tracées et et il peut y avoir des
retombées derrièrea il y aura des
bêtises comme ça il paraît que ça pour
l'instant elle a même pas encore été
placée en garde non elle a pas été placé
mais bon là cette cette cette chansonuss
c'est inadmissible euh ils vont les
retrouver cyil he les tiktokeurs là il
on le groupe ils rendre service à
personne je dis il rend service à
personne on retrouve tout le monde mais
Elon Musk ne veut pas lever
l'anonymat il y a un projet de loi en
France pour lever l' en conservant le
pseudony la problématique qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est que les gens ne font
plus la différence entre ce qu'ils
peuvent dire dans leur salon et ce qu'
pe dire publiquement et les réseaux
sociaux ont cassé cette espèce de
barrière ent de mais il faut que les
gens reviennent à la raison ce qui reste
dans le salon reste dans le salon si les
gens envie de dire des choses débes
comm les deux vidéos là que j'ai vu pour
moi voilà ça c'estil c'est rideau pour
moi il faut faut arrêter tous ces compes
toutes ces conneries tous c tous tous
ces abrutis qui foutent qui foutent le
monde dans la merde je
[Musique]
dis il vient d'agresser mon fils il a
étrlé mon fils parce que il voulait
ouvrir le sac de mon ami il a cru qu'il
vit il a agressé mon fils il l'a mis par
terre regardez c'est la bague et ils
disent excusez-moi excusez-moi je vais
porter ple boir Suzanne bonsoir ça va
bien Suzanne oui ça va merci d'être là
et vous êtes denu avec une une amie
c'est ça il aime exactement merci alors
vous êtes la maman donc de deux enfants
un grand de 11 ans et un plus petit de
de 4 ans jeudi dernier il est environ
16h vous êtes à la gare du Nord de Paris
c'est ça c'est ça donc tout se passe
bien vous et et là qu'est-ce qui se
passe on attendait notre train pour
rentrer sur l'île et j'étais au
téléphone avec mon avocat pour une autre
affaire au moment de au moment pendant
que j'étais au téléphone mon fils a
ouvert la poche de mon sac à dos pour
pour prendre du chocolat mais le
chocolat était rangé dans un autre sac
du coup il a refermer la poche et voilà
il attendait le train comme nous et je
me retourne et je vois un monsieur
étrangler mon fils par derrière du coup
le le stranguler et ça a duré très très
longtemps si voulais pas le lâcher donc
heureusement que j'ai avec un ami qui a
réussi à le à le faire lâcher parce
qu'il voulait pas lâcher du C pas dire
voilà ils sont dormis ses paupières
étaient en train de se fermer ou et il
m'a dit par la suite j'ai eu très peur
j'ai cru que j'allais mourir j'étais en
train de
m'endormir vous étiz là vous é là non
moi je suis une amie c'est moi qui RER
la vidéo sur les réseaux sociaux et qui
l' accompagné justement dans ses
démarches et ils ont mis très longtemps
avant de se présenter policier euh ils
nous ont dit stop arrêtez parce qu'on du
coup on est on se défendait comme on
pouvait c'est la police là ils ont sorti
leur bras s orange et leur bombe
lacrymogène pour nous expliquer que
c'était la police et tous les policiers
en uniforme du coup de
la de la gare sont arrivés et ils nous
ont un peu bloqué contre le mur donc
après ce qui s'était passé j'étais
hystérique je voulais marcher prendre
l'air reprendre mes esprits puce qu'on n
jamais prêt à vivre une agression comme
ça surtout de la part d'un d'un d'un
policier en civil sur un enfant surtout
surtout sur un enfant et qui et surtout
un enfant qui est déjà blessé on voit
sur la vidéo qu'il plâtre ouais donc
voilà et en fait l'histoire c'est qu'il
ils sont pris à votre fils ils ont mis
les monotes non non juste étranglé enfin
ils onont étranglé ils ont pris votre
fils pour un pick pocket c'est ça voilà
donc ils les ont fini au sol tous les
deux
incroyable votre fils comment il a réagi
à ce moment-là parce qu' le pauvre il a
dû être il a il a eu très peur on
croyait que c'était un SDF toxico qui
qui qui était en manque de quelque chose
on n pas compris on a eu très peur on
s'attendait pas à vivre
alors euh donc il voulait quoi en fait
il voulait juste en fait c'est quoi
c'est au moment il va il va dans votre
sac juste pour prendre du chocolat en
fait et voilà donc il a juste ouvert la
pochette et il a refermé instantanément
et il a rien pris sur et voilà les
policiers se sont excusés et alors
justement les policiers sont rendus
compte de leur erreur ils vous ont dit
quoi ben ils nous ont dit on est désolé
mais à 100 m on n pas vu ouais à 100 m
on a pas vu ce qui se passait puis vous
vous parliez pas donc on a on pensait
pas qu'il était avec vous mais en même
temps on vient de faire 6h de train face
à face on a plus on a plus rien à se
dire alors sur les sur les il y a votre
il y avait le le beau- père du petit qui
s'agaçait de la situation qui est devenu
virulant avec les policiers c'est ça euh
bah non ils savaiit pas ils savaient pas
encore que c'était les policiers non non
quand ils se sont présenter policier il
il s'est rien passé c'était juste avant
parce qu'on pensait voilà que c'était un
SDF et heureusement qu'il était là parce
que toute seule je sais pas ce que
j'aurais pu faire euh sur les conseils
de de ilem vous leur demandez leur
numéro d'identification ri o c'est ça et
ils ont refusé en fait ils ont refusé de
le donner ce qui est illégal et vous
vous allez vous allez porter plainte il
y a une plainte qui a été déposée oui
d'accord ils se sont excusés après les
policiers ils sont excusés mais ils ont
pas réconforté l'enfant c'està-dire que
ça a été juste à la maman ils se sont
excusés l'enfant n'a pas été réconforté
il est encore traumatisé là quand il
arrivve la Guerre du Nord je suis partie
les récupérer il était très mal il a dit
encore ici donc il est vraiment très
choqué en alors c'était en fait une
opération de sécurisation de la Gare du
Nord il y a beaucoup de problèmes gare
du Nord donc ils étaient là pour lutter
contre la délinquance et notamment les
vols à la sauvette et des policiers en
civil avaient cru repérer en votre
office un délinquant un pck pocket donc
je ne justifie pas du tout mais
j'explique ils ont cru qu'il prenaent
ils se sont précipités c'était la bque
et c'est vrai que la violence de
l'interpellation paraît disproportionnée
mais eux se sont dit enfin on démentait
l'impossible gang parce qu'il y en a
plein Gard du Nord donc ils se sont
jetés sur votre enfant et c'est vrai
avec une brutalité qui paraît
disproportionné ça on ne peut pas le
nier et pour le moment les autorités
policières réagissent très mollement
vous l'avez dit une plainte refusée je
crois que vous avez écrit au procureur
c'est ça tout à fait i oui la plainte a
été envoyée directement alors il y a un
mes amis enfin il a a il y a Bro Pomar
qui me dit du calme les bqueux traquent
les P pocket toute la journée et la gare
du Nord est un spot de ce type
d'infraction les parents pensent que le
flic est un est un SDF et les FLI P ce
que c'est un P pocket
oui bien sûr la BAC était là en civil et
puis é là pour faire le boulot mais là
il y a quand même une surréaction ben
est-ce qu'on a le droit de dire quand
même que au-delà de ça même si c'est un
vrai pilpquet et qu'il a 11 ans on on
l'étrangle pas jusqu'à ce qu'il ferme
les yeux on a le droit de le dire ça ou
c'est interdit est policiers est-ce
qu'ils reconnaissent qu'ils l'ont
étrangl non tu vois pas qu'il on voit
pas qu'il est on voit qu'il est mal on
croit un enfant de 11 ans quand il te
dit qu'il a failli mourir qu'il a les
yeux qui se ferment même si c'est un pil
pocket de n'importe quelle nationalité
n'importe je m'en fiche tu fais pas ça
un enfant de
ansit Cam le fléo et notamment à la gare
du Nord ce sont les mineurs isolé oui ça
et donc c'est ça le problème dire qu'on
peut pas savoir tout de suite si ce
gosse est un mineur isolé s'il a sa
maman à côté ou son papa on peut pas
imaginer maintenant la violence de de la
police zéro là c'est c'est c'est pas
bien alors juste pour vous avez décidé
de donc de porter plainte pour usage de
la force disproportionnée et agression
injustifiée sur un mineur on a refusé
votre plainte oui dans le commissariat
de mon quartier et le commissariat
central également pourquoi on vous a dit
quoi pour quelle raison on ne porte pas
plainte contre on prend pas de plainte
contre nos
collègues comment il va votre fils
aujourd'hui bah il est il dort il se
réveille très tôt à 5h du matin est
réveillé il vous en parle tout le temp
non ça va mais quand je pense que il
cache bien les choses pour pas
m'inquiéter mais vous avez vu un médecin
on a vu une neuropsie qu'est-ce qu' faut
faire il faut faire un une ordonnance
quelque chose hein oui
éé fait il vous a dit quoi le neuropsie
bah qu'on va commencer une thérapie pour
en pour en parler d'accord super euh
alors je tiens à dire c'est c'est
vraiment un épisode très très malheureux
hein cette affaire on pense très fort à
votre fils bien entendu voilà et on
pense qu' on espère qu'il va il va se
remettre de tout ça et c'est vrai que ça
fait du tort aux autres policiers qui
font pour la plupart leur travail à fond
s un travail formidable on l'a vu encore
tout à l'heure avec l'affaire dont j'ai
parlé et c'est vrai qu'au en ce moment
la police elle est sur les dents et elle
essaie de voilà tous les front et c'est
vrai que le le il faut pas aussi ils
sont sur tous les fronts et parfois ils
font des des des 24 24 et ils sont ils
sont ils sont en alerte maximale et
c'est vrai qu'il y a des problèmes
d'effectif il y a des problèmes de
moyens et forcément parfois il peut
avoir des
dérapag non je voulais savoir si il y
avait une enquête de l'IGPN la police
des polices qui qui avait été diligenté
demandé alors j'ai fait une une un
signalement sur la plateforme igpn ils
m'ont demandé quelques informations
complémentaires et j'ai pas de réponse
j'attends parce qu'il vont être
auditionnés ces policiers parce qu'on
m'avait dit au commissariat central que
justement j'allais être reconoqué par
l'IGPN au commissariat mais je ne pense
pas que ça va se passer comme ça quelles
ont été les explications des des
policiers c'était juste comme ça pardon
on s'est trompé ou est-ce que vous avez
pu échanger un peu plus avec eux oui bah
j'ai honnêtement j'étais pas en étage
j'avais pas du tout envie de discuter
avec eux à ce moment là mais ils nous
ont dit que à 100 m ils ont pas vu alors
je comprends pas ils sont une équipe de
plusieurs pourquoi ils envoient pas une
personne devant plus près que 100 m
peut-être à 10 m pour pour observer si
c'est bien un pick
pocket là c'était c'était un peu du
travail blé c'était vous avez vous avez
vous avez été ils ont été cool avec vous
après ou pas du tout non ben non pas du
tout ils m'ont empêché du coup d'aller
prendre l'air et lorsque en fait je me
sentais oppressée je supporte pas d'être
d'être oppressé avec 15 policiers autour
de moi milliers de gens devant le par de
la Gard du Nord qui m'observent comme si
j'étais j'étais une délinquante alors
que je suis la victime enfin on est nous
sommes les victimes euh non non ils sont
pas du tout excusé et quand j'ai voulu
partir parce que j'ai tout fait trop il
y a un policier en uniforme qui a tenté
de me mettre un coup de genou et c'est
mon c'est mon ami qui a qui a reçu le
coup au niveau des parties donc dans
l'aine c'est vraiment c'était c'est pas
passé
loin mais non on n pas très bien été
traité par suite bon écout en tout cas
on va suivre cette affaire avec intérêt
et on pense surtout nous à votre fils et
on lu
merci nous regarde juste à côté est à
côé fait un gros gros bisous voilà en
tout cas on espère qu'il va mieux parce
que c'est lui l'important le plus
important c'est lui et on pense très
très fort à lui on espère qu'il va pas
être traumatisé voilà parce que ça peut
être extrêmement traumatisant pour pour
l'instant il est malheureusement il est
il a peur de la police pour il sente
mieux et je sais que vous faites le
maximum merci
je juge pas l'ensemble de la classe
politique à l'Ô de son passé je dis
simplement je dis simplement je dis
simplementch ce qu'
dit
place pas que nous les républicains sont
un parti qui n'ont pas
[Musique]
été pas la présence des électeurs de
Marine Le Pen même si je pense qu'elle
leur et qu' les trompe souponne pas
comme JEP s'il vous plîtel quel homme
politique ne trompe pas s'il vous plaît
non c'est vrai les les promesses d'homme
politique voilà c'est un peu Daniel moi
je suis écœuré depuis l'annonce de cette
marche je suis écurée par cette vous
savez du Moretti a dit la poloche ben
c'est exactement ça vous êtes tous en
train de faire de la petite peloche et
alors toi tu as le droit de rentrer toi
tu as pas le droit de rentrer déjà
j'aimerais bien savoir si Marine Le Pen
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon viennent à cette
manifestation qui sera le plusé des des
deux déjà ça serait intéressant de voir
ça donc comme a dit Jean-Michel
l'antisémitisme il est partout c'est
c'est quelque chose de grave c'est une
cause où vraiment c'est si on n pas tous
la main dans la main dimanche c'est
foutu ça cette manifestation ne servira
à rien quand on voit la dignité de de la
maman et du frère de cet otage les les
familles d'otage ont besoin de de cette
unité tout le monde a besoin de cette
unité et vous êtes en train de vous
renvoyer des propos d'un monsieur de 95
ans non mais moi je suis écuré
excusez-moi je
pascment
emav politique politicienne aujourd'hui
on a besoin de rassemblement si le
Rassemblement National veut faire SAMU
si la fille veut contredire le père mais
la laissez les faire SAG s'agit
d'IT et j'aimerais vous rappeler quelque
chose comme à Olivier verrand puisque
vous avez l'air de croire que
l'antisémitisme est l'exclusivité de la
droite et de l'extrême droite vous
devriez lire vivorka et l'histoire de la
gauche vous avez lu vivorka est-ce que
vous savez que votre père spirituel
jores était lui-même antisémite que vous
en savez je me suis déjà su
je suis en train de vous le dire je en
train de vous dire c'est c'est on
l'entend sur toutes les chaînes l'idée
selon laquelle la droite et l'extrême
droite aurait
l'exclusivitétis fa hisor lisez vivor
lise c'est un fait important ce que je
veux dire c'est que balayons tout ça
parce que personne n'oubliera les propos
de Jean-Marie Le Pen évidemment qu'il a
été antisémite il a été condamné tro
fois pour ça compris pour
négationisoup le vousz raison plus
andour
syst laiss parler sit d'un manifestation
ce qui est absolument insupportable
c'est que tout le monde instrumentalise
tout le monde c'est-à-dire que le
rassemblement national est très très
heureux d'être là pour se faire une
sorte de washing incroyable en train de
dire que regardez nous sommes nous
sommes le paravant et et et vous vous
vous mettez vous les Juifs de France
derrière nous parce que nous nous serons
un rempart et et nous allons vous
protéger alors qu'on connaît l'histoire
de ce parti de l'autre côté on de
l'autre côté de l'chiquers on a
l'extrême gauche qui elle aussi fait son
le paravant en disant oui mais attention
nous nous sommes le paravant enfin c'est
absolument insupportable un peu de
dignité il s'agit là d'une manifestation
qui est censée être une manifestation
républicaine sur un thème qui devrait
rassembler l'ensemble des Français peu
importe leur couleurs politique peu
importe leur religion il s'agit d'une
lutte contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme bon sang est-ce que pour
une fois on pourrait arrêter de faire ce
qu'a dit Daniel c'estàdire de la petite
politique de bas étage qui ne grandit
personne dans un moment où devrait y
avoir la concorde nationale c'est
insupportable Delphine bravo Valérie ou
oui bravo Valérie euh je suis je suis
tout à fait d'accord je trouve que c'est
la foire en fait à la mauvaise foi ces
derniers temps je trouve que c'est
pathétique je trouve que c'est
pathétique d'utiliser cette guerre
effectivement de d'instrumentaliser pour
encore une fois diaboliser le
rassemblement national comme vous le
faites depuis des années sauf que depuis
des années il est au second tour au bout
d'un moment il faudra bien l'accepter
parce que les Français sont en colère et
je trouve que cette marche de
l'antisémitisme ça veut surtout dire la
marche pour la pai contre
l'antisémitisme pardon ça veut surtout
dire la marche pour la paix merci et je
pense
enfin qui qui êtes-vous pour dire un tel
ou un tel n'a pas le droit de venir
c'est une cohésion nationale avec tous
les partis de France le rassemblement
national fait partie légitime et partie
intégrante de de ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui en France et ce depuis des
années en fait donc qui êtes-vous pour
dire ceux qui ne viennent pas est-ce que
vous êtes portier de la boîte ou c'est
quoi je dis simplement aujourd'hui au
rassemblement national de dire les
choses plus clairement à la fois sur son
histoire sur son passé et sur son
présent et comme je le RA PL des
candidats à chaque élection sont exclus
pour avoir tenu des propos antisémites
quand vous avez 39 % dans un soage en
2022 des électeurs du rassemblement
national qui estiment je cite que les
Juifs ont trop de pouvoir dans le
domaine de l'économie et de la finance
moi personnellement cela me choque et je
ne dis pas au rassemblement national de
ne pas venir ils viendront ils viendront
dans une démarche politicienne ils ont
répondu à l'appel de yelbron Pivet et
deGérard Larcher au bout d'une minute
sur les réseaux sociaux pour dire nous
serons présents preuve que cela les
arrange surtout quelques jours après la
bourde et l'erreur monumentale qu'a
commise Jordane Bardella en ne parvenant
pas à condamner les propos antisémites
de Jean-Marie Le Pen vous faites de la
politique je ne vous interdis pas de
venir je dis
Simp ces gens qui votent pour pour le
rassemblement national pardon depuis des
années est-ce que ce sont des sont des
antisémites c'est ça la question queer
parce que vous décrédibiliser toutes les
personnes qui depuis des années mettent
le petit bulletin
dans message que vous le rvoyz c'est une
erreur ai vous faites de la politique
politine et vous trompez parce que c'est
la vieille lune des années 80 où on
consiste à dire à marginaliser un parti
au lieu au contraire d'en parler vous
auriez très bien pu vous auriez très
bien puz trs
bienqu
cont non non loï nêt pas seul Gill
Verdez et en
plusï je vais le faire parler voilà non
non laissez parler Gill Verdez est bien
sciux pour une fois ou mal accompagné
mercii qui vous connais bien vous
connaissez moi j'ai pris la question
pour moi c'està-dire êtes-vous d'accord
avec Olivier verrant est-ce que vous
marcheriez au côté d'élu du
rassemblement national à cette marche
ben non monsieur Odou moi je marche pas
avec vous parce que vous aviez une
occasion historique effectivement de
rompre avec ce passé qui est terrible
les chambres à gaz un point de détail du
Rafour crématoire tout Jean-Marie Le Pen
et tout vous revient là et c'est mérité
pour vous il fallait rompre avec ça si
vous
rompiez moi je vous le dis j'aurais pu
marcher j'aurais pu marcher avec vos
électeurs certainement même peut-être
avec vous mais là non et là moi je
trouve que vous êtes hypocrite parce que
vous faites vous ramassez la mise
politiquement sur le dos de cette marche
c'est pas bien ce que vous faites
plaisir plais ce dit le rassemblement
national c'est 13 millions de Français
Marine Le Pen est arrivé au second tour
avec 42 % ces 88 députés qui sont tout à
fait légitimes qui ont été élu
démocratiquement c'est aujourd'hui des
millions de Français qui se
reconnaissent dans nos idées et ne vous
en déplaise c'est aussi des millions de
nos compatriotes de confession juives je
suis député à l'Assemblée nationale je
suis vice-président du groupe d'amitié
franceisraël voilà je pense que Marine
Le Pen Jordan Bardella moi-même tous mes
collègues ont été extrêmement clairs
depuis des années Marine Le Pen en 2010
a été l'une des premières à dire que
dans des quartiers de France il ne
faisait pas bon être juif être femme ou
même être français ça a été la première
à le dire elle a été insultée pour ça
très clairement et aujourd'hui on nous
refuserait une marche républicaine une
marche d'unité mais très clairement
est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas rassembler
tous les Français est-ce que c'est pas
le sens de la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme est-ce que je reproche à
des diviseurs comme monsieur verérant
qui fait véritablement de la de la
politique politicienne et j'allais dire
de la politique bassement politicienne
c'est qu'il fait le jeu de nos ennemis
il fait le jeu de tous les antisémites
qui voit que nous sommes divisés sur le
sujet que les Français la France on
n'est pas capable d'avoir un message
d'unité sur une cause aussi sensible
aussi grave rendez-vous compte 1159
actes antisémites en un mois mais c'est
intolérable vous avez des Français
confessions juives qui ont peur chaque
jour est-ce que ça m REM l'unité quel
que soi nos divergences politiques et en
démocratie c'est important qu'il a des
divergences politiqu mais de grâce
arrêtons ces anathèmes et arrêtons
encore une fois c'est alors on va on va
revenir on va revenir sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon hier soir Jean-Luc Mélenchon
exprimé déjà son mécontentement à
travers un tweet qui n'a pas PL à tout
le monde dimanche manive de l'arc
républicain du RN à la macronie de Bron
pivé et sous prétexte d'antisémitisme
ramène Israël Palestine sans demander le
cesser le feu les amis du soutien
inconditionnel on massacre on
rendez-vous
euh c'est honteux
c'est déjà de
citer P de cit p
dans
ce
pouriwitter
PIV do signalerésol signal et on
app uneose on renie souvent
ados argument sur le rassemblement
national et la France insoumise je pense
sincèrement monsieur Odou j'entends
votre appel à l'unité mais que vous vous
servez du malheur des Juifs pour mieux
développer votre discours antimusulman
et je pense que dans le même temps
Jean-Luc Mélanchon utilise la cause
palestinienne pour masquer son ambigué
et le mot est faible deux pH d'une même
pièce oui le mot est faible sur
l'antisémitisme et je pense que vous
êtes les deux côtés d'une même pièce et
que vous vous servez l'un l'autre voilà
mon mon combat aujourd'hui parce que
vous n'êtes pas dans cet arc républicain
dans lequel je mets d'autres partis
politiques je ne vous empêcherai pas de
venir dimanche je n'empêcherai jamais
encore moins même vos électeurs de venir
mais encore une fois comme Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et comme une partie de ses
alliés aujourd'hui qui n'arrivve pas à
se départir de l'influence de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon tant que ses alliés n'auront
pas assumé l'erreur manifeste qu'ils ont
fait en s'alliant avec Jean-Luc
Mélenchon étant que le rassemblement
national n'aura pas été plus clair et
condamnant encore une fois les propos
d'antisémite tenu par Jean-Marie Le Pen
j'aurais du mal à défiler avec vous et
c'est même
impossible sur jeanluc Mélenchon juste
une chose parce qu'il faut savoir se
regarder dans la glace c'est Monsieur
Mélenchon qui a fait élire et réélir
monsieur
Macron vous la macronie c'est vous la
macronie qui avez fait élir un certain
nombre de
députés qui sont aujourd'hui des
porte-parol du Hamas à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est vous qui avez pris cette
respilité là donc très clairement ne
nous donnez pas
de parce que très clairement c'est vous
qui avez porter ces gensl encore une
fois au responsabilités où ils sont
jeanluc Mélenchon sur d'autres sujets
avait pourtant aucun problème à marcher
côté du rassemblement
national Mélenchon était bien présent
hier lors de la marche contre
[Musique]
l'islamophobie obscure congrès euh de je
ne sais quel penseurs d'avant-garde nous
sommes devant un peuple qui par millions
comporte des gens qui appartiennent à
une religion qui sont menacés et qui
montrent du doigt stigmatisé tous les
jours qui ont peur et qui se demandent
si ce pays est aussi le leur moi j'ai
j'ai j'ai une question à vous poser
pourquoi on fait pas une marche contre
l'antisémitisme et l'islamophobie en
même temps parce que c'est pas la même
chose d'accord non mais c'est une
question parce que qui revient très
souvent sur les résex l'islamophobie
n'est pas condamnable en France
l'islamophobie c'est pas s'en prendre
parce que y a une différence
l'antisémitisme c'est s'en prendre à des
personnes pour ce qu'ils sont en
l'occurrence des Juifs l'islamophobie
c'est la critique d'une religion et en
France on a le droit de critiquer toutes
les opinions religieuses c'est dans
notre Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen et je rappelle d'ailleurs
que les députés de la France insoumise
et Jean-Luc Mélenchon avaient participé
à une marche scandaleuse organisée par
l'officine islamiste du CCIS qui a été
dissoute en quelques années je lèche
professionnel ouais je l' bah mettez là
était bien présent hier lors de la
marche contre
[Musique]
l'islamophobie solidarité nous ne sommes
pas dans quelque obscure congrès il
toujours la même match céta une autre
que je voulais mais bon la régide C8 est
partie 21h4 forcément il sont déjà chez
eux en train de manger des des granolas
euh non non mais c'est vrai que ou il a
y a plein de gens qui qui posent cette
question sur les réseaux donc je je je
je me fais le porte-parole de ce que je
vois pleens dis pourquoi on fait pas une
marche pour la paix tous ensemble et
alors une marche contre l'antisémitisme
et donc est-ce que ce que vous en pensez
est-ce qu'il faut faire Mar son de
thématiques là c'est on parle on parle
de de la montée d'actes
antis pense c'est très bien que Fr de
toute confession soit derrière les
citoyens de religion juiv pour leur dire
on ne vous abandonne pas vous êtes des
enfants de la République et la
République est avec vous ça c'est prier
première chose et on peut éventuellement
évidemment et avec au contraire grand
grand plaisir là encore faire une sorte
d'arc républicain où tout tout le monde
serait là aussi alors moi je voudrais
vrais qu'on vienne sur le sujet de
départ Olivier Verant qui dit que le RN
n'a pas sa place à cette marche dimanche
Raymon toi tu as dit que tu es pas
d'accord avec Olivier verérant moi je
suis pas d'accord avec Olivier Vérant
parce que pour tous les les sujets qui
ont été dit pour tous les arguments ça
divise pourquoi il y aurait une certaine
France qui aurait le droit d'aller
manifester et pas d'autres le le moi je
dis pas le rassemblement je dis le front
le Front national c'est beaucoup de gens
qui votent ils sont pas tous antisémites
c'est pas vrai ils sont ils ont pas la
haine des Juifs il y a des gens qui
votent Front national c'est pas pour ça
qu'ils ont la haine des Juifs donc moi
je dis que les gens ont leur place ici
et au-delà de ça au-delà de ça moi ce
que je trouve un peu bon vous avez tout
dit he tout a été dit c'est pas moi qui
vais rajouter plus d' d'intellectuels
c'est j'aurais changé moi je suis
d'accord avec toi Cyril moi j'aurais
changé marche contre l'antisémitisme
j'aurais marche pour la paix ou marche
pour les otages parce que d'un côté tu
peux pas avoir un gouvernement qui dit
Inter les manifestations palestinenes et
de l'autre côté qui organise une marche
pour l'antisémitisme avait changé le
nomil avait changé le nom on sera pas
enain de
PO pjtif mais
dans demande une marche contre
l'antisémitisme moi bruti comme je suis
je me dis on aurait changé le nom on
aurait dit une marche pour les otages
une marche pour la
paiusei en quoi c'est gant je ne
comprends même pas en quoi c'est gant
dis pour une marche contre
l'antisémitisme à quel moment on doit
s'engueuler pour une marche contre le
racisme c'est quand même
ABR devent dans ce pays on est en train
de débattre de savoir si c'est opportun
de faire une marche contre le racisme on
devient
dingue j'ai vu un sondage j'ai vu un
sondage qui m'a qui'a qui m'a révolté je
dis sur les réseaux encore où je voyais
il y avait 70 % des gens qui étaient
contre cette marche sur c'est le titre
qui déconnei je vous le
dis
présidentil
plette marche contre l'antisémitisme
antisémite par définition je suis désolé
bien sûr que si et je pense que vous
vous trompez de cible là on a deux
personnes sur ce plateau qui veulent
aller à cette marche donc qui ne sont
pas antisémites par définition et vous
avez une personne qui refuse d'y aller
et qui est probablement antisémite c'est
lui qui faut condamner c'est pas ceux
qui veulent qui veulent y aller il
combattent l'antisémitisme ceux qui
refusent d'aller à cette marche et qu'
la condamn sont de fait antisémit en FO
encore une fois c'est pas ce que je dis
moi ce que je dis simplement c'est qu'un
parti qui fait justement de la politique
politicienne et qui veut faire
l'expression été employée tout à l'heure
du Green wasing sur le dos justement de
cette nouble cause qui est
l'antisémitisme n'a pas pardon fait
preuve de dcence auparavant et n'a pas
fait la condamnation claire et puissante
de ce que ce parti a pu être dans le
passé pour être présent je leur interdis
pas d'être présent je trouve qu'ils ne
sont pas décents et je trouve que sur ce
sujet ils n'ont pas été à la hauteur et
si la communauté juive rejette mais
fortement regardez les images Marine Le
Pen en 2018 lors d'une
manifestation parce qu'il a pourquoi Mar
Le
Pen question simplement pourquoi Marine
Le Pen n'-telle jamais été pourquoi
pourquoi vous n'avez pas pourquoi vous
n'avez pas renvoy pourquoi vous n'avez
pas renvoyé dos à dos le rassemblement
national et la France il y a 5 minutes
je vous
a pour Marine Le Pen n'-t-elle jamais
voyage en Israël parce qu'elle a un
problème elle a un problème avec
l'antisémitisme et qu'elle ne se sent
pas légitime à y aller vous êtes
coprésident du groupe d'amitié France
Israël B pourquoi c'est pas vrai
pourquoi n va pas RT entre Marine Le Pen
et son pèree la question
pourquo et son père suj carrière
politique pourquoi mais vous vous
résumez en fait le soutien à Israël et
au nos compatri de confession
jués la communication à faire un voyage
ou ne pas faire un
voyage une dou finiste àélection
présidentielle
pourissmo terminer je sais que ça vous
dérange je sais que ça vous dérange
parce quez bien et encore plus depuis
depuis quelques semaines que nous nous
recevons Jordan Bardella Marine Le Pen
elle-emême et nos
députés de soutiens soit qui viennent
d'Israël soit de nos compatriotes en
France qui dis pour Mar Leen nelle
jamais été en Isra mais encore une fois
vous le savez et depuis àbre d'années si
a besoin d'AB peut demander
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]